harry potter est un véritable phénomène
d'édition aux états unis en angleterre
cet orphelin magicien est le héros d'une
saga littéraire pour enfants depuis le
début de ses aventures il ya cinq ans la
folie s'est emparée des petits lecteurs
qui se sont littéralement arraché le
quatrième tome sorti le week end dernier
reportage de laure anne berrou et
jean-marc gare de la pottermania a
encore frappé cette maladie venue
d'angleterre a même poussé hors de leur
lit plusieurs centaines d'américains
samedi dernier pour un seul remède tenir
enfin le quatrième tome de la saga harry
potter
ils ont eu huit neuf ou dix ans et
d'evreux route sans sourciller les 640
pages des aventures délirantes de leur
petit magicien préféré
harry potter est un phénomène d'édition
en deux jours trois millions
d'exemplaires de ce type se sont vendus
aux etats-unis la maison d'édition
scolastique prépare d'ailleurs un
retirage de 3 autres millions cette
maladie inconnue avant 1995 est de plus
en plus répandue c'est elle qui l'a
concocté dans son laboratoire à idées
john rawlings une mère célibataire qui
écrit dans les bars d'edimbourg quand
son bébé lui en laisse le temps
discrète modeste elle ne comprend
toujours pas les raisons d'un tel succès
où trouvez vous votre inspiration
ap moyenne partout je ne sais pas de ma
tête ça vient tout seul
quel sentiment vous inspire ce succès
phénoménal
je suis moins surprise et ravie c'est
formidable ce succès l'étonnant rien
jean françois ménard
il est le premier à posséder les
ouvrages en france et pour cause c'est
lui qui traduit en français aribot il y
a je crois dans harry potter pour des
enfants matière à réflexion et matière à
émotions c'est à dire que les enfants
retrouvent dans les personnages de harry
potter leurs propres émotions ce qui est
très important pour entrer justement
dans ce monde et pour avoir le plaisir
de fréquenter c'est ce qu'ils sont
devenus des amis
son travail trouver les mots pour
décrire l'univers fantasmatique du petit
sorcier les noms les objets comme les
sucettes au sens pour vampire ou la
crème à polir pour manche à balai alors
ça c'est très important puisque le sport
favori des sorciers le quidditch se joue
sur des manches à balai 2 pincées de
traduction quelques nuits d'impression
et un test de magie au plus tard la
potion harry potter sera disponible en
france en décembre prochain